clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic merci abonne toi
j'avais une merde en plastique j'ai plus
pour des fous du savagnin robin romain
part d'ombré chaque fois je bats écoute
on ne sait quand tu veux c'est vrai tu
es un petit amour qu est ce que tu
utilises seul espoir ça c'est ça va je
vous emmerde pas tous les deux bonjour
oui bonjour alors et au revoir également
parce que j'avais je vais procéder c'est
la voilà c'est selon se suicider parce
que j'avais trouvé la veste alors je te
dis bon bah blow up sans déconner ça va
j'ai entendu ce que tu as dit que
beaucoup de peine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je voudrais vous proposer un
petit truc un peu nouveau un truc qu'on
n'a jamais fait sur dtc vous allez me
poser vos questions je vous expliquerai
à la fin comment vous allez faire je
vais y répondre
ici en vidéo mais attention on va quand
même juste mettre en place une ou deux
petites règles
1 histoire que ce soit pas la foire à la
saucisse qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
partager la vidéo en trois catégories de
questions
la première c'est celle qui fait tout
l'intérêt du truc c'est vos questions
perso sur la santé alors soyons clairs
je vais déjà dit mais je le répéterai
jamais assez je suis pas médecin
et même si je l'étais je pourrais pas
vous faire des consultations comme ça
sur youtube c'est pas comme ça que ça
marche
donc vous pouvez m'expliquer un problème
que vous avez comme ça je peux moi vous
donner des pistes mais attention je vais
pas régler votre problème et je n'ai pas
non plus vous conseillez des médicaments
par exemple je peux pas faire ça mais
n'empêche si vous avez une question et
que ça peut potentiellement intéresser
d'autres jean alesi toujours ça vaut le
coup pour que les choses soient très
claires je vais vous donner un exemple
voilà donc là typiquement on sait non un
autre exemple
[Musique]
voilà très bon exemple un cas
particulier mais la santé en milieu
carcéral c'est un vrai sujet donc ça
c'est validé la deuxième catégorie de
questions ça va être une sorte de sav
s'il ya quelque chose que vous n'avez
pas compris dans un des pc ou si vous
vous posez une question sur un sujet que
j'ai déjà traité et du coup je vais en
refaire une vidéo et bah c'est le moment
allez-y alors là encore je voudrais un
exemple voilà ça c'est validé aussi
alors et au passage la réponse est non
c'est dégueulasse et la troisième
catégorie basse et une faq assez
classique vous connaissez le principe
vous posez vos questions sur moi sur
romain sur des techs et surtout ce que
vous voulez moi je compulse tout ça je
sélectionne les questions les plus
pertinentes et j'y réponds on l'avait
déjà fait mais ça commence à remonter un
petit peu donc autant en profiter fin
est donc un exemple pour la question
pourquoi pas ça peut passer
vous pouvez sûrement trouver mieux mais
ça peut passer par contre là c'est
pareil la réponse est non voilà donc
vous avez compris le principe le mieux
pour faire tout ça c'est de m'envoyer un
mail à question d'été fait @ gmail point
com
évidemment je vais pas pouvoir répondre
à tout le monde mais je garderai quand
même vos questions et j'y répondra
peut-être une prochaine fois parce que
l'idée c'est que si ça marche bien et si
ça vous intéresse
ben pourquoi pas refaire ça de temps en
temps en attendant vous connaissez la
chanson
prenez soin de vous et prenez soin des
autres mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien
[Applaudissements]